en france 24 es momento de hablar de
economía por ello me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañero jorge hurtado jorge
bienvenido iniciamos con una noticia que
puede considerarse revolucionaria y es
que nació hoy el primer sindicato de la
cadena starbucks así de valentina y
bueno tres locales en buffalo nueva york
están haciendo prácticamente historias
al crear el primer sindicato en 50 años
de este gigante del café la votación de
la primera tienda fue
1918 a favor de la síndica
sindicalización mientras que la votación
de la segunda tienda fue de 12 a 8 en
contra de la formación del sindicato y
se espera que el voto de una tercera
tienda sea conocer en la próxima hora
starbucks que cuenta con nueve mil
locales en todo eeuu había tratado de
evitar este resultado durante meses
aduciendo que poner un representante
entre los trabajadores y la dirección de
la empresa tradicional los principios de
la misma ahora los representantes de los
empleados y la empresa deben sentarse a
negociar un acuerdo colectivo el primero
que enfrentaría a la compañía esta
decisión podría marcar un punto de
inflexión para los trabajadores en el
resto de las starwood era uno de los
mayores empleadores no sindicados de
eeuu y en eeuu sólo el 63 por ciento de
los trabajadores están sindicados un
porcentaje que es aún más bajo entre los
trabajadores de cafeterías y
restaurantes donde el nivel de
afiliación sólo alcanza el 1,2 por
ciento de la fuerza laboral bueno vamos
ahora con una encuesta que refleja que
los ingresos de los hogares
estadounidenses se incrementaron pero
también los gastos así es y esto se dio
sobre todo después de la pandemia
aumentaron ciertos ingresos pero también
aumentó en ese país la inflación a
récord histórico según una encuesta de
de asociar tres dos tercios de los
estadounidenses afirman que los gastos
de sus hogares aumentaron desde la
pandemia en comparación con sólo una
cuarta parte que dice que sus ingresos
también se incrementaron incluso el
aumento de los precios ha obligado a
cambiar algunos hábitos de muchos de
ellos según la encuesta un tercio está
conduciendo con menos frecuencia y tres
de cada diez estadounidenses dicen que
están comprando menos carne de lo que
solían consumir es que en el último año
el precio de la gasolina se incrementó
un 50 por ciento mientras que la carne
lo hizo un 15 por ciento se espera que
este viernes el gobierno publique su
último informe sobre los precios del
consumo varios economistas esperan que
la inflación se dispare un 67 por ciento
en noviembre en comparación con el año
anterior de cumplirse esta proyección
valentina sería la mayor tasa de
inflación al consumo en casi cuatro
décadas bueno ahora vamos a hablar de la
bolsa de eeuu porque hoy comenzó a
cotizar una empresa latinoamericana así
que se trata de nuba una fintech
brasileña que abrió 25 % por encima del
precio de la oferta inicial lassad y la
salida en bolsa le dio a la empresa una
capitalización de mercado de casi 52 mil
millones de dólares y la convierte en la
cuarta empresa mayor cotizada de brasil
en wall street sólo detrás de petrobras
y la minera vale pero por encima de
bancos tradicionales como el itaú y
bradesco antes se aclaró la
particularidad de este banco que suena
fintech la fintech son empresas
emergentes con tecnología dedicada al
campo financiero su nombre proviene de
los términos financieros y ofrecen más
asequible que los bancos tradicionales y
sobre todo con menos procesos no van fue
creada en 2013 por el colombiano david
vélez y la brasileña cristina y
junqueira la empresa está respaldada por
bershire de warren buffett su fundador
aseguró que la empresa se mantendrá
centrada en tres mercados principales
brasil méxico y colombia escuchemos
américa la tiene es una de las mayores
regiones del mundo los servicios
financieros en américa latina tienen una
capitalización de mercado de más de un
billón de dólares por lo que es un
mercado muy muy grande y que debería
crecer aún más en los próximos cinco o
diez años ya que se ha introducido en el
sistema a cerca del 40 por ciento de
toda la población son clientes que
estaban completamente fuera bueno vamos
ahora con los indicadores de la jornada
bueno iniciamos con walter que cerró con
pérdidas pendiente de los datos de
inflación de noviembre que serán
publicado en las próximas horas las
acciones europeas cayeron por la
precaución de los inversores de esta
nueva variante omicron de coronavirus y
en américa latina' las monedas y la
mayoría de las bolsas de valores
registraron pérdidas por el avance del
dólar y cerramos con la cifra del día
bueno la cifra del día es 600 mil
millones de dólares eso costó al
gobierno de eeuu la evasión de impuestos
en 2020 janet yellen secretaria del
tesoro de eeuu dijo que su país debe
luchar contra el lavado de dinero y la
evasión fiscal jorge muchas gracias por
esta ampliación y a ustedes por su
sintonía continúen con nosotros que hay
más en france 24
a